so anthony forbes is reporting this and
anthony by the way number one
best-selling book
debt free degree
which apparently a lot of people didn't
get the book or the idea
right uh because the student loan crisis
is at epic
proportions according to the washington
post president joe biden will not
include any student loan cancellation in
his annual budget
while the annual budget which is
expected at the end of the next week
only contains major policy plans that
have already been released
by the biden administration it's another
major setback for
student loan cancellation as a
presidential candidate biden called for
congress to cancel up to ten thousand
dollars of student loans for student
loan borrowers
but hasn't enacted any policy for
student loan cancellation
through an executive order the exclusion
of student loan cancellation isn't a
surprise
based on the latest news on student loan
cancellation it's easier to read the
writing on the wall about where biden
stands on his executive authority
to cancel student loans it's not that
biden doesn't support
student loan cancellation he does
however biden wants congress
not the president to enact student loan
cancellation
through legislation
so turns out um and and you know
there's we used to say things when i was
a kid anthony see if you've ever heard
this saying
that's like an act of congress
which means it's impossible right yeah
you know
you can't get you take forever and if
you do
if you do get you know that's easier to
get an act of congress
here people say i've heard people say
that my whole life
and so um now biden is saying it but um
yeah so the uh you know the problem
though is that people quit paying their
student loans because they think that
aoc and biden is going to come and
elizabeth warren is going to come save
them
yeah and so the default rate on student
loans have gone way up because they're
all anticipating a
forgiveness a political uh some kind of
a political activity to forgive their
loans and
it appears if it does happen it's not
going to be anytime soon and i think
the thing that is so discouraging for me
dave is i've been criticized on my show
telling people take advantage of paying
off your student loans
because you're not you're not gaining
any interest right now but the number
one
critique that i'm getting from people is
well wait i want to see what biden is
going to do with counseling the student
loans
and now look we get this we get this
like biden is not going to fight for it
and i believe
now dave i could be wrong let me say
this on the on the ramp so i could be
wrong but i do not see
congress coming in and making it happen
now it could happen but
history is showing us that it's not
going to happen
well it could happen um
but one thing's for sure not anytime
soon
that we can count on yeah because it
requires an act of congress
right and so uh it's not gonna you know
so
the problem with this is this is where
piss-poor leadership
yeah sends a signal that causes people
to engage in self-destructive behaviors
yeah yeah
meaning i'm not gonna pay my student
loans because the government's going to
let me out of them
and so now i'm in default and default by
the way screws up your credit
by the way it builds up late fees and
interest and penalties
and by the way it's going to make it
harder for you to get out
and by the way most of you owe more than
ten thousand dollars
yeah yeah the average owes about 38 000.
that's the average nationally and we
talk to people on here every day with
over a hundred
absolutely um i think the thing is this
folks
what you really need to get your head
around from an economics perspective not
a political
perspective not a moral or philosophical
you know is it your right to have your
student loan forgiven is it
philosophically
all of that really doesn't matter here's
a real practical fact for you
the government is not good at
anything definitely they're not
efficient
at anything and so anytime
anywhere in your life you are waiting on
them
to fix your life your life is going to
continue to suck
yes it's a simple principle of life yeah
yeah
you know if if anybody wearing a
superman cape with an r
or a d on it is flying across
in your vision promising you that your
life is going to be okay
and you believe them when they do that
you
are screwed now dave would you agree
uh if i said hey listen keep
riding your path keep paying your
student loan student loans keep doing it
and if congress comes in
and says i'll forgive 10 000 then you
take it but if they don't you're still
moving forward
i wouldn't say not to take it there you
go you know if it comes
but i would not adjust your current life
and your current plan based on
false promises coming out of washington
d.c because they've been coming out of
washington dc as long as it has been
there
yes yeah and so you're i'm
old a hundred percent of my
success has been the blessings of the
lord
customers that loved how we served them
and my heart but work yeah i have not
gotten
any money from washington dc they have
not sent
me any money i'm not waiting on them to
create
a successful life for dave ramsey
and if you wait on them to create a
successful life for you
your life's going to continue to suck
yeah the same thing when you're waiting
on i'm waiting on biden bucks to come in
the stimulus money
if 600 dollars changes your life your
life was already messed up baby
you were already playing small ball you
weren't playing big
it's t-ball you know so you need to get
get in
where they're throwing fast pitches and
swing for the fence honey if you want to
be
you got to play big you got to think big
and you know you're playing small ball
when you're
when you're looking for the government
to bail you out of anything now
if they start handing me some of the
money i have paid them back in any form
or format
i agree i will take that now when i take
it it's a different kind of criticism
than you get when you talk about this
yeah if i take it it's called corporate
welfare
oh lord corporate welfare oh no that was
me getting some of my money back
that's what that was any challenge i can
get my corporate welfare i'll be signing
up for that but
but i am not waiting and i'm not
adjusting my success patterns the
behaviors in my life
to uh wait on the government to fix my
life i'm not going to let them influence
me
into violating common sense in order to
do that and that's what you have is
another failed political promise right
here
absolutely so tomorrow sorry america is
pay off your debt young student loans go
after it
and if they give you some money use it
use it wisely but until then
if they do not pay your bills bottom
line
as fast as you can yeah the secret
to million of becoming a millionaire is
not waiting on the government to do it
for you
oh wow that was insightful
who thought of that i did
destroy your student loans if you want
to do that there's a book by anthony
o'neil at ramseysolutions.com right now
that'll really get you out of debt but
we're not paying any of it for you
darling you're going to pay it